hello everyone and welcome back to the
Havana Tournament of 1965 that is the
fourth Kappa Blanca a memorial
tournament it is a Heinz Gerhard Lemon
versus Robert James Fisher and this is a
game from round one in the previous
video I've shown the game Bobby Fisher
played against the vastly Smith love if
you haven't seen it first thing in the
description below please do check out
that game before you check out this one
as I am going to cover a few games from
this tournament and that one really was
a an absolute positional Masterpiece by
Fisher so do watch that now getting back
to this one from round one uh he uh
Fisher is facing uh much more
experienced player he is twice Fisher's
age 44 at the time this was played the
German Grandmaster a German Master at
the time Hans lemon later he got his
title of honorary Grandmaster one of the
few people who ever accomplished that
and he was also in 1956 he was the West
Berlin chess champion so uh you know not
someone to be trifled with and they play
a very interesting line Fisher has a win
at some point but he drops it and then
anything can happen and it's a really
crazy position you guys will have a very
fun pause the video moment so let's
check it out uh Heinz has the white
pieces in he opens with E4 yeah Fisher
goes for the Sicilian Defense Pawn to C5
Knight F3 D6 and now D4 so pretty
standard stuff open Sicilian Knight to
F6 Knight to C3 and Ponte A6 charging
Bobby to a knight of Sicilian
uh really uh in 1965 it doesn't get any
better than this uh we have Bishop D2
Knight beta D7 and now castles Fishers
plays uh Pawn to E6 transposing into the
seven anger variation and pawn to F4 we
have Pawn to B5 all pretty much standard
moves uh played even today Bishop to F3
preparing E5 to put pressure on the rook
and of course Bishop to B7 by Fisher
still we have E5 and we have Bishop
captures and F3 and now Knight captures
an F3 if you're wondering about Queen
captures and F3 it's a fun looking move
but if played to Perfection and I'm sure
uh Theory uh had this had reached this
point at that time uh you just give up
on for nothing because after captures
Queen Knight to C6 attacks the queen uh
Queen can come to B6 with check and
after King day one he captures an F for
you grab another pawn bishop captures
and now you will play Rook the C8 put
pressure on the Knight once the Knight
moves you will simply trade the Knight
captures Bishop captures and now you're
gonna play Queen to C6 you're gonna
offer Queen trade and of course white
has to decline because white sacrificed
upon for the initiative and after Bishop
B7 next move you're gonna Castle you
don't have uh well you really have
nothing to show for that sacrificed Pawn
uh okay it's a nice Bishop on E5 but um
I'm sorry about that Bishop uh Fisher
will not um be scared of by this so
instead Knight captures an F3 yeah it's
the best move and now D captures an E5 F
characters than E5 and Knight to G4
getting ready to pick up D5 Pawn we have
Queen to E2 and Fisher uh of course
plays the strongest move Pawn to B4 he
chases away the knight uh but uh Heinz
does not go back Hans marches forward
and uh what's the idea behind this the
the hanging E Pawn uh well let's see
Knight G captures an E5 Knight capture
the Knight captures an E5 Knight
captures on E5 and now we have Knight
the G5 going after the F7 Pawn but also
just putting pressure on the Knight here
uh it's a bit too optimistic if we just
go back one move Bishop player four is
the move you want to play and then
rotate the D1 and okay now it's uh it's
still a game for example Knight G6
attacks The Bachelor Brooke ad1 attacks
the queen queen delivers check Bishop
blocks check and now okay you put the
queen to C6 C7 and the game continues
uh it's a it's an okay position uh but
after Knight the G5 like I said maybe a
bit too uh optimistic we have Queen to
B6 check King to H1 and now Queen to B5
feature said all right you're uh down
material I'm offering a queen trade uh
where is this uh so-called initiative of
yours and now how do you continue uh
there is even one game from uh 2003
where Queen captures and B5 was played
but here we have Queen T1 and it is now
as of move uh 18 the disposition has
never been reached again so Fisher says
all right I'm up upon let's just uh
continue development castle and enjoy
our extra Pawn so Bishop t7 uh we have
B3 now preparing to finchetto the dark
Square Bishop on this long diagonal and
Fisher castles we have Pawn to A4
attacking the queen and queen to C5 so
putting pressure on the C2 Pawn Heinz
defends it and now Rook 8 to C8 again
puts pressure on the C2 pawn and now
it's very hard to decide some like
Bishop to B2 probably playable Rook A2
okay you can defend but that will be a
sad Rook there uh Heinz decides to play
active as he was playing active the
entire game he plays Pawn to C4 and he
says are you are you uh you know not not
scared of playing B captures on C3 Alpha
saw then I play Bishop to A3 attack your
queen you move the queen and capture the
bishop Queen caps bishop and I take the
Knight on E5 so is this playable for
fisher fisher calculates well and indeed
it is he plays B captures on C3 Alpha
saw uh Bishop to A3 Queen to C7 now
Bishop captures an E7 Queen captures and
now Queen captures an E5 how about
Fisher saw plenty moves ahead and he
knows of course that to Rook the C5
reclaims the material and he ends the
variation with a past pawn and C3 we
have Queen back to E2 and now Rook
captures on G5 we have Queen captures
and A6 now Heinz also has the two
connected pass pawns the A and B Pawn
but now Queen to be V4 puts pressure on
the pawn here on B3 Rook F to B1 and
Rook the d8 here we have Pawn to A5 and
Fisher has a clean win here with Pawn to
C2 but he misses it first he prepares it
he plays Pawn to H6 the only uh he's
still better of course but it's the only
weakish move that he played throughout
the entire game uh Heinz immediately
tries to trade off queens and Fisher
goes for it maybe keeping the Queens can
also be played with some like Queen to
B7 to threaten Checkmate but Fisher says
nope this is enough Queen captures B
captures and pawn to C2 and here if you
don't want to uh lose the game on the
spot you have to move the Rook either to
okay you can't play D1 you have to move
the either the E1 to F1 or to G1 but not
the move that everyone of course is
looking to play and that is Rook to C1
but this is exactly what Heinz played
now feel free to pause the video and win
the game for Fisher while I give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on uh winning the
first round of the capablanca fourth
capablanca Memorial Tournament in 1965
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it is Rook capture Sun A5
this is the only move that wins this is
the move Fisher played and after he
played it it was also in this position
and move 32 that uh Heinz uh Gerhard
lemon resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here that's the
problem with the Rook being on C1 now if
you capture an A5 Rook the D1 check and
of course you're getting checkmated real
capture spawn captures you bring your
queen or a rook into the game that's it
and if you don't capture an A5 what are
you playing I mean uh we're just gonna
capture on A1 and then play Rook to D1
uh with check or if you capture you just
blunder the whole Rook or there's really
nothing there's no move you can play
here yeah no no move so uh tough luck
for for lemon uh Fisher did give him a
chance to go back into the game but
instead of Rook to C1 he should have
gone rookie one Rook to F1 Rook to G1
where it still Fisher who's better
Fisher is the one who will be pushing
for the win there's just no immediate
knockout blow like there was here after
Rook to C1 so you know tough luck for
lemon but Fisher gets a win in round one
he also won round two against Miss love
the former World chess champion if you
haven't seen it first link in the
description below absolute Master Class
of a game you guys will enjoy it so do
check it out and yeah that's pretty much
it we're gonna cover some other games
not just by Fisher we're also going to
check out some other players and seems
like a very nice tournament to cover
even uh you know in its in its fullest
uh so yeah once again really hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank
Federico Torres Velasco then McCormick
James Eugene Cashman uh Uncle Musa and
Pedro Baldo for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here and thank you
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day